[Music]
in our more perfect union series we're
introducing you to an illinois man who's
on a mission like no other he wants to
learn what unites americans his name is
john and sarah he walked across listen
to this six states stopping in small
towns hoping to find out what people
have in common so a saw a small support
team traveled behind him in an rv that
served as his home base at night he
began in west hope that's in north
dakota then he walked through south
dakota nebraska kansas and oklahoma to
his final destination in the aptly named
town of i like this hope texas omar
villafranca caught up with insera near
the finish line
six states
75 towns
day 93
and nearly 1700 miles it's going to get
warm right
that's how far john and sarah traveled
by foot walking on highways and back
roads
sometimes 20 miles at a time
how did this idea coming to your head i
started to work on the retirement and
what i was going to do next i said what
do i
really love to do
what have i gotten really good at and
what has purpose and so when i put those
three things together this walk came to
life there was also the election going
on
and so i had the opportunity to combine
all of these thoughts with what i was
watching happen in the country what were
you seeing that made you want to do this
too much negativity if
we have strength on both sides if they
could come to the middle
and have a conversation and focus on
maybe what we have in common i wanted to
do something that could bring that back
he set a path straight down the middle
of america what he calls the gut of the
country it's an uncommon path but it's
on common ground and if we can encourage
people to walk to the middle and find
common ground as a nation we can bring a
voice to that
that may start a conversation he made
his way to businesses and bars cheers
cheers
stopping anyone who would talk i've
walked in north dakota
sharing his mission and asking their
perspectives on unity we're walking to
the middle you know find some common
ground exactly thank you so much for
coming through how have people opened up
to you in your journey we were invited
into people's homes
dick and judy mcqueen i'm walking to
white lake south dakota on a farm road
dick pulls up at a tractor bigger than
life sort of a john wayne type character
and he asks me if i need any help i tell
him what i'm doing and he says young man
i want you to go sit over there with my
dog ella i gotta go deliver this hay i'm
gonna be back in a half an hour i want
you to come in for supper you've gone
into a complete stranger's home yes
after they invite you exactly he was out
there just spreading this message as far
as he could by walking across america
among those strangers was josh rogers a
business owner in alito texas who felt a
connection
do you think
this is what the country needs to be
able to sit down have a beer or a cup of
coffee
and have a conversation even if there's
differences absolutely when you when you
sit down like we are right now i mean
there's just a connection right and
that's something that you know when
you're hearing opinions on tv radio
wherever you just don't you don't
literally connect with somebody despite
the divisions insera believes americans
have more in common than they think are
you finding more similarities or more
differences more similarities and i
think we have more in common than people
are willing to admit you might not solve
anything but the fact that you took the
time
to hear the other side you're going to
be a little bit different what have you
learned about yourself in this
i've learned
that listening is probably
the skill that is the most important
and when you slow things down on the
pace of walking and you are able to just
listen
the absorption of what you're getting is
so much stronger turns out people can
find common ground with a few simple
steps
for cbs mornings omar villafranca alito
texas
that's right mr and sarah we thank you
omar we thank you two for bringing this
to that story maya angelou used to say
that we are more alike than we are
different but the differences are okay
but we are definitely more alike